No, I'm being serious, man. Listen, listen, listen. You you have
to be so ticky-tacky to get upset about this. Do we would we
even disagree with that that probably that guy is a little biased
against Trump cuz he's Mexican? >> I'm going to tell her
you said that and then I'm going to mix up words to make it look
like you said the opposite. So, whatever makes her the most mad
will be the thing that you have to confront.
A powerful liberal dark money group is secretly funding some
of the biggest Democratic influencers on the internet. The program
is being funded by a powerful liberal dark money group called
the 1630 Fund that is working with Chorus. The 1630 Fund is distributing
as much as $8,000 per month to influencers. Rather than launching
the program as a public-facing initiative, however, where creators
could openly and transparently use the funds to invest in their
businesses, the program is being run in secret. Creators told
me that if they were even so much as to acknowledge they were
part of the program, the contract stipulated that they'd be kicked
out and essentially cut off financially. So, >> Well, I
understand that. But like for example, so you you assigned the
label centrist to Olivia Juliana. Which is how she self-identified.
No, she self-identifies as a progressive, right? You you use
centrist as like a pejorative, right? No, for this one we say
that like when you say >> in general you do. You you've
used You don't like the Democrats and you especially Oh my god,
the insane Are we really tone policing? This is your substantial
first engagement, right? You actually are going to get into critique
and it's just tone policing? Dude,
I
this is rough to watch already.
Well, actually, don't you like kind of use centrist in a mean
way? Don't you kind of like mean it meanly? No, no, just let
me finish. Why don't you let me finish?
I am answering your question. >> You're not. I'm asking
you >> am. Okay, what what label to make you happy so I
don't trigger you with the wrong word? What >> Something
reasonable. >> No, no, okay,
Okay, listen, I I I I I can tell you is what my reporting says
and what I found and who who I spoke to. I'm sorry, I'm not going
to keep going around in circles. It is so pointless. None of
this is
relevant. You don't seem to have this issue with any other article
that I've written about this stuff. It's crazy. I don't know
why Soy Boy is laughing. This is embarrassing content. You normally
like moderate or manage this. I don't know why you're laughing
right now. Why are you laughing? Why do you find this so funny?
Your friend is humiliating themselves. They're a complete [__]
Why are you just laughing at it? Why aren't you saying like,
"Hey, why don't we move on? Hey, why don't we do this?" Why don't
you do something? He thinks he did a good job. He actually thinks
he did a good job. He thinks he did a good job. He thinks he
won. He thinks he did That just That feeling I described about
wanting to smash a keyboard, it just spiked massively. Okay?
It's a massive Corty spike. I heard you had some criticisms of
that Live and Learn episode. That amazing you know, every episode's
the best episode ever, all right? And
um throughout all of the the snarkening of it all, I think we
got to learn something.
Right? Did you feel educated? What do you feel like you learned?
No. Um I mean, I do think it was a very chaotic. Um I would have
preferred maybe half as much of the arguing and chaos that we
had uh because as much as I think that I don't like that article
and Taylor deserves to be confronted on the way she reports it.
it's been a really long time since we did that and uh you know,
there's other things we could have brought up like the privacy
laws that she covers that we didn't. So. Sure. Yeah.
Honestly, I would have been very Sorry, one second. I would have
been very excited for that conversation to happen. It just felt
like you guys were trying to imply bias and you spent I think
30 to 40 minutes arguing about what centrists are. Would you
think there's no bias in the article if she said progressive?
Um no, but I think it's part of the addictive nature of it. I
mean, like for example, I think this is not as good of an example
as just the title and the subheading um which she's like focusing
on it is not nearly as relevant. >> That's essentially
my criticism is that there are actual indicators of bias that
you could go to if you want to talk about bias. Now, I don't
even know, like,
we could have that bias conversation after. I do have some questions
I want to ask you before we even go into this cuz it'll change
>> Yeah, sure. I just kind of jumped into this, so go ahead.
What were you going to say? >> But um
but like it there are indicators of bias. There are a lot of
indicators of bias. And
I just really thought it was strange to argue one that even if
the word progressive was there, I think you still feel like the
article's equally biased. Like, I don't think it changes anything.
And so even if you totally win that >> it's not the best
one, right? So, like, >> even if you totally win that argument,
you don't actually the argument's not done, right? So, I just
feel like >> fought us on it is kind of why it worked.
I agree that it's not the best one, but when you look at it and
say, "Taylor, you were able to call this person a progressive
in other contexts, but it's clear that you don't like Democrats.
You like to use centrist as a, you know, derogatory term for
Democrats." Wait, do you think it worked? Well, what do you mean
by worked? I mean, I think it is very clear the way that she
got defensive about this. It showed that, like, yeah, you did
have a slant here. Yeah, this clearly shows that one, you were
as soon as we call this out, you either say, "Well, isn't this
accurate?" and then you move to, "Well, actually, I didn't write
that." Um, you know, and just all these like dodgy like contradictory
answers I think make it look like, yeah, this is very clearly
displaying your
>> That she Like, if you are defending it by saying, "I
didn't write that." you are pointing out that there might be
a valid criticism of the way that this is being portrayed, right?
Like, it's a "Oh, if this is completely accurate, who cares if
you wrote it? Who cares if you didn't write it?" That's something
like, "Oh, well, that wasn't me, right?" This is a defense of
"Well, hey, if they did something bad, that's not my fault,
Well, what was her defense?
Cuz it wasn't that she didn't write it. It was like it was that
it was Olivia Julianna's characterization of herself,
Well, it's not. I mean, again, Taylor Lorenz has called her a
progressive like as recently as I do think she's lying, yeah.
I think she was being defensive. Okay. Why I mean, that wouldn't
come out on the episode. So, if you just think she's lying, you
didn't say that to her, >> like if I show you like a recent
thing, hold on, I don't have this on my screen.
I do have my screen open or can I link this to you? So, this
is from a podcast from a couple years before she wrote the article,
2023, and she's clearly able to describe in like explicit detail,
like you know, very explicitly, that this is a progressive person.
She acknowledges this. So, she says, "I've been dealing with
Twitch streamers and content creators and I would really go out
and use social media." Okay. >> I just So, even if you
prove this, like her broad argument seemed to be that it wasn't
really relevant to the article, the the phrase she used to describe
Olivia Julianna. Like it's not it's not materially changing the
article in any way. So, she was like trying to convince you guys
like not to even care about it,
The point is that the reason she has changed the descriptor that
she's using for this person is the same reason we have an issue
with the entire article, which is the bias that it's going after
people not for just transparency, as you framed it at the beginning
of our conversation, but because she's trying to attack these
people as these like Democratic shills who get all their talking
points and extrapolate and play into all of the abuse that came
out after this from people running away with the story, right?
Sure. So, at best, let's say all of that is true. At best, that's
like 0.1% of whatever bias you're trying to point to there. Okay.
So, you're you're basically calling your guest like a liar who
you don't trust already right off the bat and spending all this
time hammering down on it. Now, she said it doesn't really matter.
This went through a bunch of vetting, right? Like there's a whole
bunch of stuff going into this and I feel like probably when
you say she has a bias, you mean there's a bias in a way that
makes the article inaccurate or makes the article a poor piece
of journalism, right? Because obviously she has a bias, like
everybody's got a bias,
Yeah, so like proving she has a bias here, you would need to
prove she has a bias that that negatively affects the article.
I don't think this does. I don't think this takes even like a
a tiny step forward in doing that. >> Not even a tiny step
cuz I agree this is not the best I really I really think this
is like inconsequential in every possible way.
Um what if she had said Zionist? I don't know if I would care
about Zionist. Like
Yeah, yeah, yeah. No, I I I pretty sure I realized that Olivia
like supports like some sort of Zionist policy to some degree,
right? I I don't know. Like don't like fact check me on this,
but like let's just say she supported like a very explicitly
Zionist candidate, right? And if you were to say this is a Zionist
uh you know Zionist creator Olivia Juliana, right? This is not
inaccurate if that was the case that she supported some Zionist
policy, but it's clear that you're showing oh you're not making
this about transparency. You're trying to paint the narrative
that Zionists in this case uh would give talking points to these
people so that they would not deviate from Zionist lines and
then uh you know uh make Yeah, I think you're reading a massive
amount into like a qualifier that is like actually not like I
don't think that's being said to be honest with you. I think
you guys are like just reading a massive amount into this qualifier
that
Like to be honest I don't think she cared about that label. I
don't think she's using it that way. And even if she was, you
basically just have to accuse her of being a liar. And there
are other indicators of her bias like her tweets after the fact
that are just way better things to argue on. So like to me you're
basically calling your guest a liar and if you think she's a
liar to that level, I don't even know why you'd have her on.
Uh wait, sorry. One more time? No, I don't even know why you'd
have her on in the first place. Assume she's like lying to that
extent cuz again, if she was doing that, you would expect it
to like follow through. Like I would expect it to happen with
somebody who's a character throughout the entire article. But
how many times is Olivia Juliana
I I'm I'm not sure this is relevant. So what I'm saying is this
was one of many things that you could point to that shows that
this is not some objective analysis of transparency. That the
reasons we have an issue with it is this was meant to make Democrats
look like this evil controlling group. And this is one of the
things that is not the best and I agree that points to this and
that she will take a label like progressive that she would otherwise
use to describe this person and switch it to something that she
uses a pejorative to paint these people as these like centrist
do-nothing feckless people, right? So that's just a small part.
I do think it moves it in a small part. I don't think it completely
proves a point. Now if you're asking like okay here here can
I just give you an example? Like let's say you were trying to
prove somebody was anti-Zionist, they didn't like Israel. And
you could show that when they use the Israeli flag in their article,
they actually made the the shade of blue like five color five
shades of blue off.
Right? Because they wanted to disrespect Israel. Do you think
given an entire article, an entire body of work, do you think
focusing on that even though it is off, you can prove it's off
and it's like they've used the right flag in other articles,
do you think it's important to focus on that? Do you think that's
like a good use of your time?
Um spending more than 10 minutes on it maybe not, but if there
was some established precedent where people did this in such
a way like there's a some meme of how to disrespect Israel and
it's like hey and you're doing it in your article. And then your
defense of that is oh well I didn't put that emoji in. It's like
okay well someone did and someone is playing off of this trope
of making centrist look bad. So either you or someone who helped
you write this article is trying to frame it in such a way to
paint Democrats as evil centrist. That's the point. So no it's
not the most important part of the framing to say that this is
why she has all this bias. But it's it's relevant. It absolutely
is. And honestly like yeah getting hung up on it for a really
long time is annoying, but I don't think it's something you can
just ignore. I think this is like So, this is going to go to
another thing with I think the only people you could convince
with this argument are people who will already buy into the framing
that like the article is completely disingenuous and like it's
people who agree with you politically essentially. That's the
problem with that article because people who, you know, felt
satisfied by that conversation were probably people who already
thought it was uh biased. So, that that might be true. I don't
know. I haven't had a lot of independent or undecided people
reach out to me and say, "Oh, well, now I see, you know, you
you exposed her. You really got it right." Like most of those
people were probably already biased. So, that That was all to
say that like I think we could have a way better conversation
so we could just like
drop that part and talk about other
What do you want to talk about? I think it's Well, I'll ask you
the questions first. Basically, a couple things about Livin'
Learnin' and how you saw the conversation.
And I just like to me
I feel like beating my head into the brick wall on that one feels
kind of pointless cuz it's again
We'll get into it later, I guess, when we talk about the the
criticisms that would be good or what I think would be good criticisms,
I guess. But, I want to ask you these questions first. So, I
I just kind of want to bury it cuz it seems like we're running
into the same problem where we might spend our entire talk talking
about why we were concerned about centrists. You know what I
mean? >> Yeah, I mean at any point if you want to like
pause and try to reframe, like feel free. Um like, you know,
I I know it's what it's like to get lost in the weeds, so Somebody
Somebody in my chat says Josiah uses centrist pejoratively all
the time. Is he a secret tankie?
No, but if he wrote an article and he tried to pretend like that's
not how he was writing it, I'm like What But, could he use centrist
in a Could he I sometimes use centrist pejoratively, yeah. You
Hold on, but do you think that if Josiah told you he didn't use
it pejoratively, he was using it descriptively cuz it didn't
matter and he didn't even really check into the person, he just
like threw it on there cuz it was irrelevant to the rest of the
article, would you believe him on that?
Um
I this is kind of a weird question cuz I know him a lot more
personally and would believe him.
But, if
if it was at the same level of connection I had with Taylor,
I would say, "No, not necessarily." Like, I I don't think that's
true. Like, especially if it's the same if he if if you just
attached Desiree's name to this article, I wouldn't somehow come
away from that and say like, "Oh, actually no, now it makes total
sense." I would have the same criticism for it. What I would
have loved as a conversation there, like I think would have been
really awesome, is like what responsibility to journalists have
for how people use their their work, right? And what what steps
should they take? Like, what's Taylor's opinion on that? Because
I think the best criticism you could do of Taylor in this case
is that her opinions that she stated on Twitter and in interviews
were different. And not obviously she's not under the editorial
gun anymore, right? So, she she doesn't have an editor. She can
say whatever she wants, and she is saying things that go beyond
what the article says. So, I would love to I would have loved
that conversation to be had. You know what I'm saying? Like,
"Hey, what what do you Don't you think that we should have a
discussion about that?" Because it seemed like what you guys
were trying to do was to use her tweets, her commentary after
the fact, to invalidate the article. But, the article, in my
opinion, was basically unimpeachable. And her tweets after the
fact might make it might color it
Right? But, those are her tweets after the fact, and she is possibly
doing some harm to her journalism. But, that is a whole different
conversation than just, "Oh, well, I actually don't like this
article. I don't think it's accurate at >> Hold on, let
me get in cuz you said a bunch of things. One, I agree that would
be a interesting conversation, and we barely scratched the surface
of like, "Hey, like all these people kind of ran away with claims
that aren't made in the article. Is this irresponsible?" And
we really had to press her to say that I I don't think she wanted
to say that, but I think it is, especially because people that
she's more friendly with did some of that. Um, two, I think her
tweets afterwards absolutely matter. I know it's not in the article,
but it shows that the person who wrote this has very, you know,
certain beliefs about these sorts of people and what is being
said. And had I you know, I can't prove that. do you think we
were unaware of that? Do you think most people are broadly unaware
of her beliefs going into that reading that article?
Um I don't think most people
like who read Wired know who Taylor Lorenz is and like, "Oh,
this is a good Taylor Lorenz article. I think this is a very
bubbly like people like you and me who are online and are like
just follow a journalist instead of I follow what Wired published
today." Okay, so you made a different argument on the podcast,
if I remember correctly. You can tell me if I'm wrong in this.
I don't want to go back and try to find a clip, so Sure. >> like
on the podcast
Well, it sounded to me like on the podcast you said that she
was using those words, the word centrist, cuz she knew who was
going to be reading this article. Implying that a lot of the
people that most of the people reading the article would be people
who agreed with her and and could see that centrist label as
a slight. But if you're arguing that most of Wired is unaware
of that and not in that culture, then I think you've just sort
of undone your own argument for why that label was effective
or useful or indicative of anything.
I think she's catering to a certain audience in that writing.
Uh I think that again, that's also framing it from the bubble
that we're in. If I had to guess, most people who read this are
not going to care at all about that. But even if you did want
to cater that audience and have that view going in, which I think
she does, if you're trying to make it look like these people
are these nefarious puppets of the DNC, uh and you're writing
to this audience who doesn't really understand that, then yeah,
the centrist uh label there isn't signaling to the audience that
she is like more amicable to. That's painting centrist as bad
and then having the people who otherwise wouldn't be in this
bubble now start to think, "Oh, centrist is bad. Centrists are
these you know, progressive or you know, formerly progressive
people who are now like puppeted by the DNC, right?" >> somebody
reading that would actually
retroactively read the centrist they they would think They'd
read that article and then they go, "Oh, when he called when
she called Olivia Juliana centrist, she meant centrist are bad."
No, I think they read it and say, "Look at these people who are
taking money from this organization to just repeat these talking
points. They're little >> Yes. And then, knowing that they
were described as centrist, will now take that word centrist
and think, "Centrist bad." That's what I think.
Well, I think I mean, centrist definitely isn't even
They think DNC bad or Democrats bad or establishment bad. DNC
bad, Democrats bad, Democrats bad, Democrats bad, Democrats are
centrist. Again, the centrist thing is not harped on repeatedly.
The DNC thing's harped on repeatedly. Sure. Again, this is not
the strongest point.
I totally am in agreement there, but I don't think it's irrelevant.
Okay. All right. I Sorry, I I heard that and then I I wanted
to go back to it really quickly. Okay. Uh one thing basically
I I would have wanted you guys to talk about was essentially
if you don't believe Taylor's word, I do feel like having her
there to have that conversation is why I like beating your head
against the wall with that whole line of questioning. I felt
like was not very substantial.
Is if you have her there, then you can ask her questions about
the article. And I do think like if you go to her Glenn Greenwald
interview or the comment on Hasan, if you're just asking like
if you frame it in a non-adversarial way, which I understand
is hard cuz you guys are friends with the Course people and you
feel like the article is quite >> be clear, I don't know
about everyone else. I can't speak for them. I don't know if
I know anyone in Course. Um
Was Adam Mockler in Course? I I know Adam. I think possibly,
but it regardless, connections or or, you know, second-order
connections, one of the two. It's going to be pretty pretty absent
for me. My My concern is like I just I didn't like this and I
wanted to talk about it. That would be fair. I wasn't the one
really majorly confronting, but Hutch was the one who
what, manifesto or whatever, so um but I I agreed with most of
his criticisms. But I agree, I mean, like if you look at what
Guy said at the end, um her answer on Hasan or the way he says,
like, "How do you think, you know, what should I disclose?" One,
the conversation discloses better when you're not yelling at
each other. But two, I think you can still expose that bias and
like what she's saying and that's very telling without making
her like, you know, have to like be on the defensive and yelling
at her. So, yeah, I I I I agree. Those are probably better ways
to go about it. Sure. Sure. Sure. Sure. I think um the the bias
to me really it's like I know the bias going into the article.
Sorry, guys. Didn't drink enough water before I started the stream.
I knew the bias going into the article. I didn't feel like the
bias in the article seeped in in a way that actually made the
article bad.
So, that was a little like weird for me to read. >> So,
you go even further than that,
Well, I think unimpeachable on truth >> Unimpeachable,
excuse me. Unimpeachable on truth grounds. I would say the the
subtitle, right? The There's the title and then the subtitle.
The subtitle
They had to tow the party line or like it's a state secret.
>> But to me, um to me those will be clickbait to get people
to click in and go to read the article. And it's ambiguous. And
the ambiguity is totally resolved by reading the article.
So, I like it makes it very clear what they're paid for, what
they what they mean by all these things, right?
So, if I were to describe to you Chorus in the way that like
Brian Tyler Cohen does in his video uh defending this and like
when he I I'm sure you saw that like his response to Taylor.
And it's like, "Hey, this is a program. We want to help out influencers
to find out how they're going to build their LLCs and all this
other stuff. Give them tips on how to grow. And we pay some of
them to do this." That might be I would say an understatement
in some ways because obviously they're they're they're getting
they're getting more they're getting more than just that. It's
just like the simplified on paper version. But I think that's
a much more fair way than the entirety of this article which
paints it as some sort of like information propaganda
like funneling system. Which if you look through and it's like,
"Well, you say it's unimpeachable. None of this is true." And
it's like, "Okay."
I I'm just saying that like I was watching streams when Brian
Tyler Cohen was going around and talking about his his like driving
like impetus to create Chorus. You remember what that was, right?
Were you around for that? Um maybe not that specific conversation
he might have had. I don't watch a lot of BTC, but like basically
my understanding is like he's like, "Hey, there's this giant
media apparatus of of
you know, content creation and media on the right. Why don't
we have something like this, right?" Have you ever like logged
into Twitter and you get this sense that Republicans had a Monday
morning meeting and they coordinated their talking points and
they came out and they were all on the same page. I want to do
that for Democrats. I believe is something close to verbatim
the pitch he was giving, right? Okay.
So, when people say, "Does that not sound like it's a organization
built to push the party line?" Push the party line, I think is
carrying a lot of weight in that. For example,
anyone can come together with a group of amicable and friendly
people have similar opinions and say like, "How do we tackle
this, right?" Like I don't think it's nefarious that Republicans
are like, "Hey guys, let's like find out like what you know,
what are we saying about this?" There's the >> Yeah, I
don't I was just talking about this recently. >> either.
I would say it the nefarious part of this to me is the lack of
disclosure. That's the nefarious part or what seems a little
more nefarious. But the way you just framed it is like pushing
the party line. Well, what's pushing the party line? Like if
he does this, for example, well no, let me go back to what I
was saying. There's this thing called like the DNC war room that
I'm now part of which is like they have like a group chat and
I don't know if it's every day cuz I don't check it as much cuz
the notifications won't stop pinging me. But like they'll put
out literal I think they'll call them this. They'll say, "Here
are today's talking points." And they will say like, "Look, like
this is what happened. Here's the news. Like here's like what
Trump did." Now, you could just take this and then push the party
line and be like, "And this is all good and everything they do
is bad and everything Democrats did and all these things they
accomplished are good." But what happens is you're just like,
"Oh, this is a way for me to disseminate all the information
that has happened in a nice concentrated spot. Here's clips of
people talking. Here's all this stuff. Now, go make your own
information about this. They don't say you can't say this and
you can't say that. Now, of course, there's going to be some
bias of like how they're framing this, what kind of points they're
giving us, what they're focusing on. But, the idea that this
is pushing the party line, especially enforced to push the party
line or paid to push the party line, is far beyond hey, here's
a bunch of stuff. Let's all coordinate and talk about this so
everyone can have a like a similar understanding of what's going
on. So, I subscribe to that, but like I I don't think this is
pushing the party line. Again, I do think it's hyperbolic. I
do think pushing the party line, if I say you got paid to push
the party line, I mean I'm paying you to push some specific points
that I'm giving you, right? Right. >> hyperbolic, but I
think that hyperbole in the title to me is resolved by the article,
the material of the article itself, right? That ambiguity is
resolved in the article and you learn what they're being paid
for and what the restrictions are. I don't know about that. I
mean, if that were the case, why would so many people come away
from this article implying that like the DNC is paying people
to tow the party line and that they can't deviate from the talking
points or they'll get kicked out, which is not what the article
says, right? If that were the case, which is not true, Let's
be real. If they were deep If they were deviating between, you
know, step one and two or cohort one and two. Let's say some
people got into both cohorts. If they were deviating significantly
from between cohort one and two, let's say they were becoming
more Republican, more libertarian, arguing against a lot of Dem
policies, they obviously wouldn't be getting paid anymore, right?
Um I mean, if they were Republicans,
Like you would just filter them out,
Sure, but again, pushing the party line is very different from
you have the exact opposite goals of the party, which are, I
think, a big stretch up apart. And so, if you're like, "Hey,
I have this thing. It's created by Democrats and we're pushing,
you know, the big the tent, like what's in the tent forward."
And this person's like, "I'm a neo-Nazi." And it's like, "Whoa,
he's not pushing the party line." Like, that's kind of a big
deal. thing. more hyperbolic than I am, right? Well, I was just
saying that like just
deviating isn't enough and it's clear to me that there is a wide
stretch of ideas here. Now, some people ran away and said, "Hey,
if anyone was like criticizing Israel, you can't, you know, be
part of this program anymore." I have yet to see that substantiated.
>> anybody said that. >> I would be No, people were
saying it. Taylor doesn't say it in the article, but people coming
across from this away from this article But Taylor didn't even
say that in her response after the fact. That's other people
making it up. So, if other people take >> Wait, literally
zero information Wait, what about the that up. where she said,
"Primarily, these creators,
you know, were these like pro-Israel
Is this not the implication that they weren't allowed to deviate
based on >> she just say pro-Israel?
Uh let me read what it says. I'll bring it up again. Yeah, I
could read it to you, too, if you want. Oh, if you have it up,
sure. Yeah, I can confirm that Hasan [__] was on
Before Before you read it. Before Before you read it. If that's
the case, uh you don't Don't got me questions. Just say it. Like
if you know. I'm I'm I'm not trying to got you. >> It's
that they've not spoken out about Palestine. As in As in silence
on this is one of the things that she noticed as an attribute.
Do you think that's inaccurate given like a lot of your own friends
have basically elected to not really cover Palestine? One sec.
One sec. I can't multitask. Um sorry. All right. Okay, I have
it up. Ask your
So, it was or they have not spoken out about Palestine. They
don't talk about Gaza. Now, given the reporting on David Pakman,
BTC, a couple of these people meeting up and basically agreeing
that it's probably not a good thing. It's not a good thing. You
can't really build unity on Palestine, right?
Do you not think that's vaguely accurate? That probably most
of the people they're looking for are people who focus on domestic
issues.
I I I can't say for sure if this is vaguely accurate. I haven't
done an assessment of like all the creators. Like, what I'm saying
is >> Given that it's being run by people who made that
value judgment, do you think that would not be something like,
"Hey, we want to focus on domestic issues. We will have a couple
but probably we're just going to want people who are pretty close
to our beliefs. That doesn't That's not nefarious and that to
me that seems like >> pretty close again there's a lot
of but there's a lot of adjectives here that I think are like
being construed in different ways, right? Pretty close to our
beliefs, what does that mean? If the implication of that people
are walking away from this and especially here who says not spoken
out about Palestine and are pro-Israel it's like the implication
being if you spoke out about Palestine or even slightly not pro-Israel
that you'd be kicked out of this program and that's how some
people read it and ran away with it, right? And >> not
implied by that tweet at all.
That you'd be kicked out. >> influencers involved appear
to be primarily centrist pro-Israelis who have not spoken out
about Palestine pro-Israel and the implication being that combining
this with the if you don't tow the party Well, you just said
if they're you know, they have to be closely pretty closely aligned,
right? This to me
reads that way like oh yeah and if they're not closely aligned
on these things they're going to get kicked out. Whereas the
reason I used the hyperbolic But nobody's saying kicked out.
You're saying kicked out. Where's the implication of kicked out?
Kicked out or or not given the money or what like not being part
of the party not invited to the program. Not not included, right?
Sure. Like a higher chance of not being picked. Do you feel like
that's inaccurate? Do you Do you I'm not asking you for proof.
I'm saying gut feeling. Do you think that's inaccurate?
Um well, it's not substantiated in the article. That's for sure.
>> I didn't ask I literally I asked I don't need proof.
I'm asking for your gut feeling. My gut feeling on like
Do I think that people who are like super
you know, genocide Joey people probably won't be included? Yeah,
no. The reason I'm saying it that way is because Well, listen
cuz like They're looking for people who align, right? To to a
significant degree but not like oh they have to be so pretty
close that like if they deviate even slightly. And the reason
I say that is the the way the article portrays it, right? when
they say Uh, in the same example who's not invited into the White
House correspondents or the the White House press briefings?
And it's like people who were lightly critical. The implication
being one, the DNC can't handle any criticism basically. Light
criticism is enough for them to get them kicked out. Which, to
be fair, in 2024 they definitely were pretty dodgy with some
criticisms. They didn't go on things that were going to be like
even a little looking bad. But, the implication being there that
like even just a slight deviation in the same way with chorus
is going to get you out of this tent and you're out in. And some
of the people referenced in the article about like who's getting
kicked out are people that what way more than lightly critically.
>> saying kicked out and I I just want any substantiation
on the the verb kicked out. I I'm going to stop using that. That
might be incorrect. What I'm saying is not included. Like right?
Like not included in these programs or not included and invited
to these White House things, right? These people were not like,
oh like I don't like Joe Biden's this policy. It's like you know
pretty hard hitting like criticisms or if not like more heavy
criticisms. And I think it's completely reasonable, by the way,
if you're like so far beyond >> It is. >> criticizing
of your own. I actually think it's totally reasonable to make
a group like this.
Okay. Okay. So, right there she says they haven't spoken out
about Israel and she thinks her personal bias is that's bad,
but she left that out of the article. She just said descriptively
what it was. Why if the DNC didn't want to really talk about
Israel in 2024, why is it even weird for her to to like point
that out? That it's that that's just descriptively the case.
Because now you're taking her article, which is already implying
things that might not necessarily be true, that you say, well,
but does it vibe that it might be true? Which it did, clearly.
That's why all these people came out with these criticisms that
were unsubstantiated, right? And now she is adding that fuel
to that fire by saying, here is the specific type of policy I'm
talking about. Oh man, I sorry. I came up with this literally
this isn't written down. So, this is me on the fly. So, I'm not
going to have this crystallized. But, to me, I think the idea
that it's nefarious or bad to pay people to push your party messaging
is just not true. What's nefarious there is having the restrictions,
like the restrictions that prevent you from disclosing it. That's
nefarious to me. What The idea that you just build a pro-DNC
thing that is going to push DNC message messaging, that doesn't
seem bad to me. And I'm not sure that that's there and bad in
the article. I think the other practices are what make it bad
and make it nefarious.
So, it's it's not bad to push the party line, but it is First
of all, I I believe you when you say that. However,
do you think Taylor or the people that like I'm describing when
I say the bias, do you think they think the party line is good?
>> Yes. Yeah, no, bad. They think it's bad. Right? Yeah,
obviously bad. That's what I That Sorry, I said that leading
in that obviously her bias her her bias is that it's bad that
they do this, right? But I don't think that's revealed in the
article. I think the article is descriptively true. And I think
the article lays out some other things that are nefarious, regardless
of whether or not calling a genocide a genocide is really critical
to the DNC. I'm actually thinking like I'm looking at this like
she literally says
Republicans have been have been like working on stuff like this
I believe she's she's hinted at stuff. Does she not message Does
she not mention Tenney in here? She talks about Republicans doing
it as well, how Republicans have a lot of like a flood of money
in there. I honestly God do not get the impression from the article
that she is saying it's just evil to do this to to give this
money to Democrats.
Um evil to do this to give this money Democrats. I don't know
if I necessarily agree with that framing either. Um but again,
when she's bringing up Tenney Does she bring up Tenney in this
article? I don't know if she does. I don't know if I'm opening
the wrong one. Oh, no, here it is. I have it over here. Um yeah,
she does. >> the difference in how DNC people want to go
top-down and Tenney media and stuff is going bottom-up. Or like
Sorry, RNC is going bottom-up. Do you I think what Tenney did
is evil. Do you? Um why is it evil? I I would say any foreign
>> putting money into a Canadian >> Canadian organization
to pay people to have specific types of content. Right? >> Like
that's not true.
Right? No, it's not.
No. Oh, that's right. Excuse me. They already knew that they
were going to make content that would agree with them. Right.
Sorry, excuse me. They didn't say like you have to make this
video. Although I think there were some discussions of that through
Tenet. >> Do you see Do you see how that just what you
just said there maps completely on to the idea of filtering only
hiring people who want to say what you want to what you want
to get out >> about manufacturing consent? Sure, but the
difference here is that one of these is these people are literally
spouting
Russian propaganda and we also have to have discussions about
like yeah, let's align on like what the Russian propaganda framing
of this like Ukrainian parade attack is. Like that's not technically
paying them to have that, but that's a big difference from here's
a place where we can disseminate
Democrat talking points and you can go against the Democratic
Party and we're not going to cut your funding there or maybe
they will not invite people who are like super uber critical
to the Democratic Party, but like there's clearly a big enough
spectrum of people here that it's not just like the same >> do
you think >> Russian shills from a different government,
right? >> But do you think if I found one of those Tenet
media creators who said something negative about Russia or one
of the Russia's interests
and they didn't get cut off from that program, do you think that
would prove that they weren't being or they weren't being told
to push Russian propaganda?
No, but it would definitely hurt the criticism for sure. For
example, >> hurt it that much? Be honest. Would it hurt
it that much?
It depends on how much it was, right? Like if you go back and
it's like oh, every other video Tim Pool is like Putin's evil,
right? I would say >> Like two out of 90 people break on
Palestine? Like basically it would be one creator made like a
one or two videos breaking away on Russia. It would not affect
the criticism 1% man. Be serious.
Be serious man. Listen, listen, listen. If the the criticism
of the tenant media thing is these people are getting money from
a foreign government to push the country line, right? This is
the same accusation as in the article, right? And if you're looking
at this and saying, well, hold
Like a good chunk of these people are not even pushing the party
line like or the country line or whatever what the [__]
you talking about. Like that would undermine it and then you
would have to substantiate this with more information. It's up
so I'm doing the Israel thing where basically one or two people
came
like two. Yeah. So two people came out and they were like pro-Palestine
and they talked about the genocide, right? And so significantly
that the resources they're using are very likely still
almost entirely to pushing their thing. And if I had one or two
examples like they have four for chorus. The accusation is that
having those one or two examples doesn't hurt the allegation
that the DNC is pushing their own messaging through hiring people
who align with them. Right. But if you're saying that in this
article as this article is like implying that like these deviations
would get you not invited or these deviations were all controlled
these people were controlled, right? This is the implication
coming away from it. And these people clearly aren't. Then then
the argument
I don't I don't think that's implied by the article. It says
they have they have on restrictions on content.
Go go to the fire. On content, right?
Restrictions on content, funneling stuff through the newsroom,
right? Like the idea that there's this top-down like sort of
like apparatus that's making these people do stay within the
bounds of what chorus deems acceptable, right? Now obviously
what chorus deems acceptable, you could say, well, they say,
you know, the neo-Nazi or whatever like steps outside of those
bounds. So that's clearly not acceptable. They're not inviting
these people. But I'm saying the implication of this article
is it's the party line. That's the only thing that's acceptable.
And so if you have people, even if it's one, just one person
who's not, you know, pushing the party line on any of these things,
It's like okay, this undermines it to an extent cuz either they're
not doing that or they are, but they're keeping a couple people
to throw a bone just to like play defense, right? And then the
accusation has to shift to okay, how many of these people are
they throwing in there to hide the fact that they're doing that?
And then that's a completely different thing you have to >> I
don't think it's No, I don't think it's like that. I think basically
so long as you're like you're always going to have some pet issues
where you deviate and so long as it's like 90% effective, you're
fine. Anyway, it's It's okay. I do want to talk about the fun
of >> argument, right? Like that's saying like okay, they
are paid to pay the uh tow the party line and they're going to
throw a bone to some of these people as people did this to uh
the progressive victory, right? I don't know if you heard about
this, but um they put Dylan Burns on and it's like look, this
thing's full of tankies. They would never They don't give a [__]
about Ukraine. They just want to [__] on >> to
be clear, there's only one group of really deranged people who
are saying things like that. You push back against that basically
immediately, did you not? Like it wasn't just tankies. Yep. >> There
might be some communists in there. I don't doubt that, but it's
different from a tanky. But sure. No, I'm saying these were the
accusations. I'm not agreeing with these accusations, right?
And so these accusations are coming out and I'm like well hold
on, how can you say that the they're, you know, this ideologically
captured tanky org when this is happening? They have Dylan Burns
on to talk about Ukraine and they're like oh, that was just to
throw Ukraine a bone. That was just to hide this. And now I think
that's very clearly I mean unless they're just keep throwing
bones. I mean like this organization has now come out and be
like hey, like we're going to work with Jack Ukraine. We're going
to like, you know, change to make sure we don't have that perception.
Um this is going to undermine those accusations and whether or
not they're planning that for defense, you have to now prove
that, but right now they're putting their money where their mouth
is. So if you're going to make the accusation that they're towing
the party line, they're telling these creators to tow the party
line, they're keeping them within these confines, they're not
inviting people who will step outside and then there's people
that do step outside, then it seems that either this isn't true
or you now have to prove that they're doing this as cover, right?
Yeah, I think you just really disingenuously framed the progressive
victory thing in Dylan Burns and centering Dylan Burns and taking
a pledge that people are going to commit to Ukraine. That is
way, way, way, way, way beyond having two of your creators occasionally
making a Tik Tok about Palestine. But it's fine. I don't I'm
okay on that point. >> Sure, but that's more. If they they
did way more, I would agree with >> yeah, like orders of
magnitude more. So like you're saying it changes things because
they've actually done a total shift of what they're actually
what they're doing like at an those level. Like their their entire
the entire organization is going to make people sign a pledge
to support Ukraine. Like that's >> Yeah, that's that's
that's like top down, right? Or in the same way like yeah, to
make this a 100% equivalent, I'll agree it's not one-to-one.
Then Crooked would have to be like, all right, like all you have
to do is support Democrats, but we'll accept literally any opinion
and like they have literal people calling Joe Biden like genocide
Joe in there, right? So what what would then the level have to
be for you to say, okay, they're not, excuse me, towing the party
line. Uh like how critical are people allowed to be? How many
people are they allowed to be? Like I think my my idea of this,
the way I conceive of this, and again, uh this isn't written
out in the article, the way I just conceive of this from listening
to Brian Tyler Cohen when he first made this, what they've been
trying to go for is they do want to push the party line. And
there's nothing wrong with that.
Okay. They're a political party in the United States. They're
allowed to do >> when you say they want to push the party
I get different vibes. I mean, I have to see what Brian said,
but is this like I want to support the Democrats no matter what
because I want to win? Is it I want to support the entire Democratic
platform? Like I I'm confused about like what the implication
of him saying I want to have this like pro-Democrat
>> have something where we we have a bunch of creators
that we provide support to monetarily and in terms of information.
And with that information, it's going to be tightly what the
information we're going to give them, they could go outside of
it, but we're going to give them information on the daily and
we're going to also do education sessions that all align with
what this party wants to push. Maybe even a little more progressive
than what the party wants to push. Maybe I'm going to put my
own spin on it cuz I'm a progressive. I'm Brian Tyler Cohen.
I can do whatever I want. So, we're going to go even more progressive,
and I'm going to push all of this messaging the same way. I'm
going to give all of these people the tools, and I know that
because I'm going to argue these points well, and I'm going to
craft these points well, they're going to take them and disseminate
them. That's what I think the goal of Course
Um based on the way you added the stuff there, that seems mostly
fair, right? Like it's like, okay, I'm going to take >> fair.
It's from the Democratic platform, and then maybe be more progressive
about it, right? Then then what What part of that First of all,
that does you would It sounds like you're saying that that's
fine, right? Like that and all that stuff as a project is fine.
>> If the money's coming from an unknown source, that
makes it a little more, you know, like, okay, well, what's going
on? What are you accepting this here? I actually don't care about
the unknown source all that much, as long as it's got a middleman
that I could trust, and I assume most Most people who consume
Democrat media trust Brian Tyler Cohen. Right? He's sort of the
steward of this. He's the face on it. If it's totally blind,
and you don't know anybody there, then you get concerned about
who's getting let in and what other nefarious purposes could
be undertaken there. But, so long as it's got that main face,
Brian Tyler Cohen, I'm kind of fine with it, personally. So,
okay.
If you read that article,
do you think you would come away with your opinion, which is
hey, all of this is totally fine, it's just the disclosure I
have a problem with, cuz I think not at all. >> I read
that article, and I came away with that opinion, so yes.
>> asking if I think the average person
I think the average person would be concerned that
that basically
a bunch of like dark money's flowing into these groups, and they're
saying you can't tell anybody what we're saying to you, or that
we're paying you. That is the nefarious part to me, and I think
that is the core part of the article that that seems most off-putting,
and is like the central violation that's happening, is these
people aren't even allowed to tell you that they're paid. They're
not allowed >> another thing that would have been great
to talk about, by the way, is basically like I think it got brought
up at some point, but just more time on what should the standard
be for how you have to disclose this stuff? Yeah. was like I
don't know I agree at the end.
Yeah. Um sorry, I got distracted for a second. I was moderating
the chat which I never have to. Um
I mean I can I I don't know if we're going to see eye to eye
on this. Like when I look at the way that this is framed as like
this sort of nefarious thing. I don't think it's just the dark
money part that this is nefarious. I think it's the talking about
the DNC as this arm of like controlling centrist like you know
like we can't let anyone do You understand you're just like you're
just like rambling right now, right? I I am and and we're going
to go in circles. So I don't know like we can move past that.
We literally just see a difference in >> want to if you
want to take some time after this and try to show me like the
phrases you think that portray this as like centrist are bad,
Democrats are bad by by nature Democrats are bad. >> on.
You already agreed cuz like if you try to like accuse someone
of being like racist and it's like well, I didn't even say the
N-word in like any of my like tweet and it's like okay, but hold
on like like you Have you ever seen like a racist person talk
about black people and they say blacks? And this is just like
the telltale sign that like oh Huh? Oh, I know a creator who
does that all the time.
which one? Bad Logic but Oh, okay. I don't I don't know who that
is. But yeah, it's like it's almost always like a sign of like
all right.
This doesn't mean you're racist necessarily. Like maybe maybe
you're just talking about black people and maybe that's just
how you used it. But more often than not this is going to be
like a signal of like all right, there seems to be a way that
you're talking about this and like that's that's framing something.
And so if I can't show you the the phrase Democrats are bad cuz
you know, it doesn't say that. Um Sorry, I said the phrase that
implies Democrats are bad at a base level. Right. And it's like
when you when you say like that's the whole reason we harp so
much on the centrist thing which is not the strongest one. Like
like I said the subheader is and you say okay, well, that's the
clickbait which I think is a little bit like burying the lead.
Like okay, maybe it is clickbait but like clickbait insofar as
it's sensationalizing this and the in your opinion the only way
to come overcome that sensation sensational sensational sensationalizing
sensationalizing the only way to over since Thank you. The only
way to overcome this is to read the article and say, "Okay,
I I see now that this is just about the disclosure. This was
a sensational headline." I don't think that's the way this article
is going to be taken after you finish that. And so when I felt
like or have you thought that it's possible that the nefarious
nature or or any of this stuff is actually you in your feelings
about this article because you are like the people who are being
criticized. You are like You are literally like an emblem of
Well, sorry. I think it's I think it's criticizing people who
are willing to work with Democrats. Like sorry that are within
the Democrat tent or Well, it's actually criticizing a couple
things. It criticizes their strategy, which I also kind of agree
with in some ways, but it's like criticizing
um or it's it's criticizing this group that is a DNC aligned
group that is making people sign like dubiously ethical disclosure
agreements.
And I think you see yourself as Democrat
I mean, obviously I'm Democrat aligned. The question is when
I I did not read this article
understanding even I didn't know what course was until I saw
this. And when I read it and I hear both sides of the story and
I'm like, "Okay, like this is how I felt like it seemed to portray
this as some big evil thing." And then I go and look into it.
I'm like, "Okay, it doesn't seem that bad." That's like my neutral
I mean, obviously not neutral. Like I knew who Taylor was before.
But like going into this I'm like, "Okay, like what she's saying?
What are the
It was like a oh my initial instinct is maybe this is a bias
to go, "Oh, may- maybe this is true and I want to make sure it's
not, right?" Because I'm reading it based on the way like uh
it seems to be portrayed to me. Not like I think she's trying
to paint it this way.
I So I don't mean to cut you off. I'm so sorry for doing that.
>> No, it's fine. Um I I think it's being critical of how
Democrats are trying to
bend this space to their will. It is being critical of that.
If the disclosures were happening, I don't think you'd be nearly
I don't I don't think it would feel nearly as critical.
Like that is that is the problem. It's criticizing people you
align with. And whether or not you knew what course was, whether
or not you knew anything, you knew going into this article that
you're dem-aligned, that you are like a liberal, and it is criticizing
this primary core group of Democrats and how they are essentially
trying to bend some people in the content creation space more
to what they want, right? Or not even trying to do that. Trying
to astroturf the content creation space to make their ideas seem
more popular.
But see how you just phrased it, right? Like you can agree
that that is what's happening or that's bad if that's the case,
but but that's meant to portray it as bad, right? Democrats are
astroturfing,
which implies fake consent,
changing the opinions of these creators. >> is No, no,
no, no, no, no, no. Astroturfing is you are propping up creators
who aren't winning in like the marketplace of ideas. And you
By the way, you could make an argument this is good. They're
not winning the marketplace of ideas. Their content is not breaking
through, so you're going to give them money, you're going to
give them resources so that they can continue to make content
and put more of it out, making your ideas more like take up more
of that marketplace.
Right, right. But the again, when you're like That's what astroturfing
is, by the
Yeah, it's it's it's like fake grassroots, right? That's why
it's called astroturf.
Yes. But that's what this is. Like
Wait. Is that what's happening is or is it taking people who
already have most of these opinions on a wide spectrum, by the
way, and saying we want to prop up things that ultimately are
going to be pro-Democrat, whether or not that's 100% pro-Democrat
or even 20% pro-Democrat? >> By the way, I'm not
I'm not looting astroturfing, and I would think doing pro-Democrat
things is probably good so long as the Republicans are trying
to blow up the planet. Sure.
I mean, yeah, like the the ultimate like maximalist guy position
is like we should take as much dark money and maybe even like
you know I don't I don't know if he he would agree but like you
know some people are like yeah, let's just lie. Let's just put
more lying propaganda out, right? But like whether or not like
that's like necessary evil fire with fire thing, I don't think
this is even close to evil. You don't either. You think it's
the the the disclosure part that's right? And so >> I think
it's bad and the way I'm seeing the difference between how you
receive it and I receive it is you feel like attacked. You the
things you care about are being attacked and I'm looking at it
dispassionately. It's how I I feel about this. If you were a
Republican, I don't think you care if Taylor wrote this article
and she was biased in the exact opposite direction, same magnitude,
exact opposite direction towards being more pro DNC, I think
you would have zero problem with this article. I think everybody
who currently criticizes it would have zero problem with this
So, she's saying all the same facts about the disclosure stuff,
which I think are not like in a vacuum, but she's saying and
it's good.
She's basically yeah, she's hinting that it's good that finally
finally Democrats are fighting back against this legion of Republican
dark money that comes into all of their media channels.
So, I mean yeah, like if the article was not trying to tear down
the creators trying to do a thing that I think is helping the
Democrats right now, I wouldn't criticize >> tearing down
the creators?
Because it's portraying Course as this like nefarious thing that's
Why is it >> forcing astroturfing. Well, you you're saying
yourself, right? Like astroturfing is a negative term, right?
>> I said no, I it's not a negative term. It's a descriptive
term. It's descriptive. You are artificially inflating the the
artificially inflating your opinion in the marketplace of ideas.
If I say propaganda,
you and I agree there's obviously things that are propaganda
that are probably good, right? But people don't say propaganda
positively almost ever. It's almost always a negative.
Okay, but you understand that if I let's say I was botting my
stream for views and you were like, "You're botting." And I was
like, "No, no, no, no, no. I'm
I'm simply paying a service to raise the visibility of my stream."
You understand that like Right. I could say that. But you understand
you understand that I'm the one who's
right? Astroturfing is deceptively increasing the perception
of a grassroots movement. That's what this is. You are paying
people who aren't making enough money to put up more content
that agrees with you. Is that necessarily what is happening,
or is it >> That is people who already agree with >> have
to agree with me. It's absolutely what is happening. There are
people being paid. There are people who are Democrat-aligned
people that are getting paid money to improve their platforms
and, you know, spread their voices. Now, when I say astroturf
what I'm thinking is there is a lack of you know, some sort of
like movement for these people. Like there's some movement like
like
I just got I can't think of an example of what I mean. But let's
not try to deviate. I'll use an analogy. The idea of like this
otherwise wouldn't be like an opinion that people hold, and we're
paying to make it an opinion people hold. Instead of hey, we
want to amplify the voices that already have this opinion, who
are you know, need help getting traction, getting into the algorithm,
making thumbnails, making LLC, and they're failing because either
they don't have the resources or they just don't know what to
do. That's very different from like what I see as let's manufacture
a narrative. That's what I hear when I hear astroturf. So maybe
I have a wrong perception, but I never heard Again, I think hey
guys, let's prop up the smaller voices. That's not what I hear
when I hear astroturf. Yeah, it's really unfortunate cuz I do
think what's happening here is you are you're hearing me say
something that's descriptively true, and it has a negative connotation,
and you don't like it, but I'm saying like >> it's a negative
connotation? Try to hold off. That's what I'm saying. Well, usually
people don't like astroturfing. But when it's astroturfing like
basically okay, we have an election. There's a group of aliens
against humans. The aliens want to blow up Earth. And >> Yeah.
actually, we're going to Astroturf on our side to keep Earth
alive.
Right, right. But what you're describing what happened is >> That's
literally what's happening. You are Astroturfing. People see
it as bad and we need to do it to to for a better cause, which
is like for the greater good we will Astroturf, right? Yes. Right,
but it's still got the negative connotation. I e. this like now
we're getting back to the beginning, which is like this was negatively
framed.
Well, I don't know. Did she use the word Astroturf? I'm using
the word Astroturf because that's what's being described. But
I don't know if she used that word. >> what what what what
what what what what what what what what what what what what what
what what what what what what
Which is what she was describing. >> not her negative framing,
just so you know. It's me trying to explain to you and use a
word that means precisely what is happening. >> in the
article. So, if the article is objectively describing this, what
you're describing is the article says that after the fact >> be
in the descriptive like in the description of the phrase. The
negative loading is in the word. You don't like the word Astroturfing.
She didn't use it. She described the process of Astroturfing.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. >> negative description
is not there in her article. Well, not by virtue of me calling
it Astroturfing. She could describe Astroturfing and I can tell
you that that's happening.
But like >> And I'm I'm saying does Astroturf just mean
I'm giving money to smaller creators who have my opinion cuz
I don't think that's what Astroturf is. Astroturf to me >> it
It comes from the fact >> it's if it's for if it's for
making your your opinion seem more popular than it is. And by
the way, >> Is that That's That's the problem. Wait, stop.
Wait, stop. Wait, stop. Wait, stop. Wait, stop. Wait, stop. Wait,
stop. Wait, stop. Wait, I have to cuz like this is the key distinction,
right? Go. Go. Go. Is it more popular than it Is that what's
happening? Is it's like oh, not enough people
My understanding of this is there's a lot of support on the Democratic
Party for various reasons. They're super unpopular. Right, don't
get me wrong. But the idea of like we want these people to see
our ideas is not we're making it more popular, making it seem
more popular. This key thing is there is "Oh, let's pay these
like people that are like I'm independent and I don't have any
talking points and oh, you know what? I just happen to agree
with all these people." That that would be the astroturfing,
right?
Okay. Sorry. >> The astroturfing is the the amount of content
and the overall views that a specific opinion is getting. If
you pay people with your views to create more content, you are
astroturfing that marketplace of content. Make it seem like it
grassroots way your opinion is more popular than it is. And the
other point that makes that particular egregious here is the
restrictions on disclosures. So, you are trying to make it look
like a popular grassroots movement rather than you are paying
people to go out and promote your stuff, right? You're actually
present preventing them from doing something they could think
is ethical, right?
In disclosing that they're being paid as a part of like a political
operation. Can you remind me again what they're not allowed to
disclose? Cuz my understanding is probably people >> part
of this Chorus They're They're part of this Chorus program. Once
they sign this, they can't disclose their relationship with Chorus
or that they're being paid functionally at all or their connection
to 1630. Is their language. Well, the connection to 1630 I think
is that's a separate thing because my understanding is most of
these people wouldn't even know about that. So, that's like how
like you know, maybe they're not >> 1630 funds on their
checks.
I understand that, but they don't understand like the relation
I don't think many of these content creators and you know, maybe
I'm underestimating content creators, but you know, most people
aren't like oh, like what's the funding? I got paid by Progressive
Victory once, right? I don't know exactly where all that money
comes from. Uh if you told me it was a dark money campaign today
and there was this big thing that came out, I would be like oh,
I guess. I didn't know. I didn't [__] >> Progressive
Victory on your check, the thing that signs your check, you wouldn't
Google that? >> No, I What I'm saying is I don't know every
mechanism of funding that goes into this, right?
So, I'm saying the 1630 thing's a little separate, but the main
point there is >> Well, sorry. Are they disclosing that
they're part >> It's not separate though, cuz I just need
to correct real quick. It says you can't disclose your relationship
with the 1630 fund. 1630 fund being on your checks. Don't talk
about the 1630 fund. That's what it says. It's not really separate,
it's the same thing. Don't discuss it. >> No, what What
I'm saying is even if it's on your check, like okay, yeah, maybe
you go look that up and it's like, okay, just don't talk about
the 1630 fund, sure. What I'm saying is these people don't understand
these funding mechanisms necessarily and it's like, oh, like
oh, you know, I'm definitely being paid by this secret dark money
group and I'm not allowed to talk about it. I'm talking about
specifically why I'm saying that's adjacent is
when they're saying they can't be part of chorus, are they just
saying they can't be paid? Cuz all of these people are like their
faces are on it. They could be part of chorus and a lot of people
came away from this article thinking, oh, you couldn't even be
a part of chorus, like this is a secret
>> I don't know anybody. So, here's the thing. Can you
find me somebody who is a part of chorus, a part of the pilot
who came out before
Alice article
and was not a part of chorus before that with an announced partnership
that is outside of signing that contract for the pilot program?
Uh, no. I I don't know off the top of my So, I do I don't doubt
that some people were allowed to disclose after because it looks
better for you. But unfortunately, I think if you took this money,
it says in your contract, do not disclose your relationship with
chorus. If you sign the contract, you take the money, do not
disclose your relationship with chorus is in the
>> Now So, the idea that a lot of people have disclosed
it's outside of that relationship, right? It's outside.
Outside of Wait, what relationship? The paid relationship. I'm
necessarily sure this is true. Um, I last time I looked at the
article, it seemed that there were plenty of people that did
this. I don't have them off the top of my head. I don't know
if someone channel wants to give it to me. Like the the chat
help line, but >> you want me to walk through that again?
Uh, sorry. Basically, there were people who So, I've got, um,
let's see. How could we do this? Progressive Victory. Progressive
Victory is like going to let you go to an event, right? But they
don't pay you. And you say, oh, I'm doing this event with Progressive
Victory. I'm a part of Progressive Victory, right? And then they
start a separate program with different funding and they say
and in the contract it says, you will not disclose that you're
a part of this program or your relationship with Progressive
Victory or the 1630 fund or any of this, right? Now, you might
ask them, wait, what does that mean cuz I've already said I'm
a part of Progressive Victory. But if you sign that contract,
you've signed something that says do not disclose this
And so most of the people weren't a part of Chorus before the
pilot program and they would not be able to disclose. And the
fact that people disclosed before that is not dispositive of
them being barred from disclosing. It means that it's actually
not even relevant. I I understand your point.
there's a bunch of questions here. One, what they're not allowed
to disclose. Cuz saying they're not allowed to be say they're
part of Chorus, we know that's not true. It's about the money,
right? Is what you're claiming, right? >> we don't know
that that's not true. I don't I've not seen that that's not I've
not seen that. >> either, right? Does the maybe the article
implies it, but this is not substantiated, right? >> And
regardless, regardless, it's in the contract anyway. And so there's
already a problem with it being in the contract regardless of
if they enforce it against people or not. Um well, it depends
on what the language of the contract is specifically asking for.
If it's saying, hey, like again, the reason we got on this was
we were talking about is there a secret group trying to disseminate
Democrat talking points and saying you can't talk about this,
right? Are they not disclosing that they're part of Chorus? Are
they not disclosing that they're getting paid by the 1630 fund?
Are they not disclosing that they get talking points or that
they have meetings, right? These are all again that it's it's
the relationship with Chorus. So I'm guessing and I I'm just
I'm not guessing. Here's I'll read again, according to copies
of the contract viewed by Wired that creators signed, the influencers
are not allowed to disclose the relationship with Chorus or the
1630 fund or functionally that they're being paid at all. What
I'm telling you is if you were not a part of Chorus before this
and you joined to to join this part this program right here you
are barred according to To contract, you are barred from discussing
your relationship with Corus. Do you disagree with that? And
do you have any proof >> I'm not entirely sure this is
true based on what I've seen and I'm I don't want to use a different
example, but it's like in the later in the article where she's
talking about funneling. I remember specifically cuz I had the
language of the contract that said >> about Ali. So Ali
seems to be a So regardless, okay, first of all, I guess I This
is a separate point, but what I'm saying is when I read that
in the article and I say, "Well, I'm not necessarily sure this
is true." If I just read this article, I would say, "Oh, well,
that's what the article says, right?" But knowing how this article
portrays things that I think are misleading, when I can look
at these other examples, I say, "Well, I'm not quite sure this
is the case." Um now obviously BTC and all these other people
are going to deny that. Uh they haven't really read this article.
I can't know for sure. But it's incumbent on them to show me
that that is indeed how this language reads when it seems to
me that they've already >> Why? made some dubious Because
if they've already made some dubious claim No, not before by
the way. Now when you say uh like looking at the funneling thing,
it's like they had to go through them. They're funneling all
of their connections and interviews to them and I'm like, "Well,
hold on. If you read this, it seems to be, 'Hey, if you're doing
something that is through our network, do it through our network.
If you do it outside of our network, just let us know if it's
relevant to Corus,' which is like a completely normal thing the
way I read this. Me reading this now in the article, it's like,
"Well, hold on. This portrays it like oh but they weren't allowed
to like go outside and they were all funneled through." And it's
like, "Okay, well, now I'm reading this other claim that says
they couldn't disclose the relationship." I'm not quite sure
>> do? Funneling, they put it all from wider thing into
a narrow thing. So if all of the information about who everybody
networks with is going through one point, what could I call that?
A
So saying that they funnel their feed their bookings through
Corus is not >> which said they could go outside of Corus
completely and they just should let them know. >> It doesn't
say Well, if as far as I can tell, it doesn't say that they are
um Well, what I There is something later where I think they can
cancel these things. But they they need to be aware of all of
it. You know why they need to be aware of all of it, right?
Right, because of the the legality of like, "Hey, if you're going
to do any sort of political work, and you're invoking us, like
we need to make sure that you're not making us break the law."
Right. >> Okay, perfect, cuz I'm so I'm so glad we can
go here. So, one, I do think it's already funneling all of your
bookings through, and I think it's required, and I think they
would need to have the ability to cancel these bookings in certain
cases because of the legality.
Right? Well, wait. So, actually, the fact that you're going to
>> point. Why is it funneling? Like, to me, the second
point in that
>> one specific nexus.
You're taking a bunch of disparate information and funneling
it through one specific nexus.
So, if you're booking things, and it's like, "Hey, if you're
booking Chorus-related stuff, you can use the newsroom. And also,
you don't have to do that, but if you do it that is Chorus-related,
let us know cuz you're part of this program. And also, anything
else you do that's not related to Chorus is not even mentioned
in this contract." This does It's not a Follow me.
Do Wait, why would they Why would you ever care about It's It's
all for the electioneering stuff. >> it's like, "What?"
I I don't think it's implied in the article that they have to
do like all collabs or something, is it?
No, it's not. That's kind of my point, but that's like it it
Oh, sorry. No, it's not in the contract, but in the article,
it's implied that like, "Yeah, like everything they did had to
go through Chorus." And that's the implication I got reading
this. Um but, following the initial outreach, many creators expressed
concern about some stipulations. According to copies of contract
viewed by Wired, again, not even Tele Lorenzo's claim, but Wired's
Wired's claim, "Creators in the program must funnel all bookings
with lawmakers and political leaders through Chorus. Creators
also have to loop Chorus in on any independently organized engagements
with government officials or political leaders." How do you get
the idea that other collabs outside of those specific things
are being
uh somehow bottlenecked by Chorus?
So, if I Okay, if I read the contract, tell me if this is an
unfair way to phrase it that is not the way this is phrased in
the article. Well, can we first could you could you take the
thing I sent you and could you just explain what you disagree
with here? Wait, which thing did you send me? Well, I'm going
to send it to you as well. I got it up on the screen. Is that
what you're talking about? Yeah, it's this this text but following
the initial >> Yeah, yeah, I I have the text. Okay, right.
So, it says according to copies of the contract viewed by Wired
Creators in the program must funnel all bookings with all makers
and political leaders through Chorus. If I were to read the contract,
which hold on, let me see if I can bring that up. It doesn't
matter. I mean it does, but the point is if I were to read the
contract, it would say, "Hey, according to copies of the contract,
all Chorus-related
interactions with lawmakers
either must go through their tool or
if you're going to do it outside of their tool, must be notifying
Chorus, which is completely normal. This makes it seem like if
you do anything with someone in politics,
you have to let us know and you have to like, you know, we're
controlling of all of that. That's how this reads. I don't think
that's a fair assessment of what's in the
Where's controlling? It's a fully collaborate with them. Oh,
the the quote from the creator is is not
like maybe you could say that you would like because you guys
again are are aligned with the people of Chorus, you would like
if they made it very clear that the quote from the creator that
follows, right, is not necessarily true and that it's really
about coordination rather than fully collaborate with them. That
might imply something else.
Well, sure. I wasn't even going to bring that up, but but that
was kind of addressed when we asked her about this, like do you
have evidence that like this was done, that there was this sort
of like controlling nature of it and she one of the creators
expressed concerns, right? And it's like, well, okay, that's
not the question, right? Like obviously this guy had a concern.
Obviously, maybe he misinterpreted it, maybe he was accurate,
maybe this is what the contract would have been in force if this
had come up. But like that's a separate point. Like that's not
what they were we were asking her or what Hutch was asking her.
Yeah, but it it literally that doesn't matter. The The improper
act is contractually obligating these things, right? That's what
people are concerned about, and that's what's alleged in the
article. I'm reading this contract in such a way, and I'm worried
about this. This is a fair thing to say. If you are writing it
in an article saying people were worried about it, and then not
really providing the language of the contract that doesn't seem
to imply exactly what you're saying, you're painting it as if
that concern is true, not that it's just a concern, right?
Why You understand that like this is
It's very concerning to me that people don't understand that
contract stipulations, even if people tell you they're not going
to be enforced, you never open yourself up to violating contract
stipulations just because somebody tells you they're not going
to be enforced. Like that is not the way it works. If they have
no intention of enforcing it, then they wouldn't include it in
the contract.
But you're already under the assumption that what is happening
here is like, "Hey, here's this huge risk, right?" Now, this
could have been something where they brought this up, and they're
like, "Oh, well, that's not at all our intention, but just in
case we'll edit that for you, right?" But when I read that contract,
and I'm not a legalese expert, you're looking at this, and it's
like, "Okay, not nowhere in this says that like they have total
control over what we say."
then I wouldn't even worry about the fact that it's like, "Well,
they'll never enforce it." It's like, "Well, hold on, there's
nothing to enforce here that I think I have a disagreement with."
Which is a different opinion from what this creator said. He
read it and said, "Oh, I think they're going to control, and
I have to comply 100% with everything." And that's why he left,
right? But like There's no step here that's missing, which is
There's no
fully compliant, whatever, right? Like the point being The step
here is like, you know, I'm sure you know this, like
you know, contract written by like your job or any other like
potentially nefarious institution, or you know, like a Disney
lawyer. Hey, where's control? You You are saying things that
aren't there in the text.
Is the implication wrong here? Control? I'm sorry, do you want
me to say fully compliant? He doesn't want to give the contact
info. He gets an interview with Zoran. He doesn't want to give
the contact info to them.
Okay. Where's the control? If I have to fully collaborate, I
have to give their my interview to them. Like they they control
my interviews, right? They control who I talk to and how I talk
to >> He's saying he doesn't want to involve
I I I don't know what to say. I mean like it Sure, I guess if
that's how you're reading this. I I'm just not seeing that at
all. It's like oh I just didn't want to let them know I was talking
to Zoran. I don't want them to do my Zoran interview. This is
implied by the This is implied by the reading and it's why I
think you're biased, right? So creators also have to loop course
in on any independently organized engagements with government
officials or political leaders. And then it does the quote and
he says I don't want to give that to them. To me, that's he doesn't
want to give that to them as in loop them in on this thing with
a different government official because it's an independently
organized thing, right?
And it's implied by the article. The progression of the article
>> it to them? Is it let them know I'm doing my >> but
that's a quote. They're they're saying they're they're just doing
the quote. You you have to be so picky tacky to get upset about
this. I'm not
>> They have the exact language there.
>> They have the exact language there that they're reading
the contract and then they give the quote about how the creator
felt.
I'm going to try this one more time. And I sorry, that sounds
really condescending. I I understand we see this differently.
What I'm trying to say is that when you read this these two
it is almost 100% clear to me that what they're saying is Chorus
had control over the interviews and even if you didn't go through
their program, you still had to give them the information.
I think one, I do think they had some way depending on if you
were using resources. I think they had the ability to control
it and they had to have that. They had to have that. >> are
you fighting me on that then? Oh, that's sorry, that's the next
line which is I creators in the program are not allowed to use
any funds or resources that they receive as a part of the program
to make content that supports or opposes any political candidate
or campaign without expressing express authorization from Chorus.
That I think, basically if you if you said I'm interviewing Zoran
and I'm going to say vote for Zoran and they said they would
need to be able to say no to that for obvious reasons, right?
You would totally agree to that. >> Right. If you're using
their money, right? They have to. Otherwise, they're breaking
the law, right? Yes. Okay. >> Okay. Perfect. Why were you
fighting me on the control point if you think that is what it's
saying? Uh because that's not what the guy's talking about, right?
That's not what the guy's talking about. It's That's not what's
um the previous paragraph's talking about. This is about contacts.
This is about like essentially sharing your >> Sorry. Which
one are you reading? Uh sorry. The first two paragraphs of this
like section. >> the first
What do you mean? These are completely related. It's like the
the next paragraph. I Sorry. What are you now talking about?
You said this isn't related. This is about like a completely
new point. It's like no, they're not allowed to use any funds
they will receive as part of the program to make contact and
support the >> So, I think the quote goes with the above
paragraph. That's what If I If I get Zoran and he wants to do
an interview with me, I don't want to give that to them. He's
saying I don't want to loop them in. I don't want to have them
get my contact info. I got to hook up with Zoran. I don't want
to share
Okay. And then it says the next paragraph and you think this
is like completely unrelated to the previous
Well, hold on. It's saying that if they have given you funds,
then they need
Oh, that's true.
So, where's the nefarious element?
Because the way this is Look, I'm going to say objectively true
thing. Tell me if this is you think this is like super
Chorus needs to know that you're not using their funds to explicitly
support or oppose a political candidate unless they have authorization
because they are part of a 501c4.
If they don't do that, they could go to jail. That's a objectively
true statement. Probably face fines or have their 501c4
dissolved, yeah. Yeah, okay.
>> Do you think that this paragraph is portraying this
in such a way that shows Chorus as some like manipulative
No. top-down structure where it says "They can't do that." Then
why doesn't it mention anything about those rules that I said
that you know? They might not know about it.
Wouldn't it have been great if somebody had let them know? >> author,
right? Wouldn't have great Would it have been great if somebody
let them know that that's why it was happening?
Cuz there are two basically equivalent reads on >> that
be your job if you're writing the story to know that? >> to
to know or sorry, I trust like Brian Tyler Cohen and a lot of
these people. But if you don't inherently trust him, then there's
another read of this. And what happens in all of these news stories
is they go, "Hey, this is the story we have. Would you like to
comment on it? We're going to run with it if you don't want to
comment on it." But that's not how journalism works. If you're
making a >> That is how journalism works. No, if you make
a claim about someone and they don't comment, that doesn't mean
everything that you said was true. >> that both of these
reads are very very possible, right? >> whether or not
you what? Both of these reads are Like you could think that that's
because of politics or whatever, but regardless, you could also
I don't even think it's that controlling to say if we gave you
money for this interview, we get we get to control if it happens
or not or you have to tell us if you're doing it for electioneering.
Well, right, but it is control, right? And if you don't include
the reason they're doing this, which is because if they don't
do this, it's illegal, you're framing it as if they're this like
nefarious controlling group that's like, "Ah, yeah, we get to
decide who you talk to. You can't support people we don't >> of
control, but it seems like a reasonable form of control outside
of the 501c4
thing. Like it's not an unreasonable form of control outside
of the 501c4 >> be unreasonable if not for the 501c4 thing,
right? No, I'm saying it wouldn't be unreasonable even if they
weren't a 501c4. If we give you money to do us something, we
want author we want to be able to authorize you doing electioneering.
Okay. Outside of the 501c4 structure, it still would not be a
nefarious thing. So, if in the article
the whole thing is framed as these people are being controlled
and they can't say what they want to because of the money they're
getting and it's
And then you get to that part and you see they can't even support
the specific >> Where is it saying they can't say what
they want to? In the In the material the meat of the
If they say we you can't support this political person unless
we tell you to is this not we're controlling what you're allowed
to say? >> Unless if we're giving you money so all you
have to do to do what you want to do right if we're giving you
money for that thing. I believe it says explicitly if you're
using your funds from Chorus for this thing. Mhm. Right? Right.
That is not controlling what people can say. >> That is.
You're saying I you can't do what you do outside of that. Because
in the previous two paragraphs it says even if you did something
outside you'd have to funnel it through us right? Implication
being you can't deviate in any way. >> Loop them in. Loop
them in.
Right you and I know it's just loop them in but the way this
is written is >> says loop them in. It's in the article.
IT'S IN THE TEXT. >> I I know but when I say loop them
in you and I the implication of this to you and me which we're
both acknowledging is just hey you just have to let them know
to make sure that like you know some crazy [__] isn't
going to happen. No that is the What do you think What do you
think loop them in means man? What are you doing dog? Loop them
in. If you're I understand like
You okay I'm going to just write this rewrite this article right
now right? If I say >> means to include someone in communication
discussions or decisions regarding a specific project or topic
ensuring they're informed. No no I know I know I know what loop
them in means. What what I'm saying is when you and I say loop
them in we don't mean hey you have to let Chorus
uh you know these specific things and by the way if they don't
like it they they're going to pull your funding or they might
you know push you into a box and say no you can't do that. When
you and I say loop them in it's just like hey just let them know
right? Cuz that's what this is and worst case scenario they need
to know that you're not breaking the law. That's what loop them
in means to me and you right? I truly don't think it's like that
far off in the article. I don't think there I don't think the
implication that if we give you money to do something that we
want to be able to say yes or no to it is like some nefarious
some nefarious >> don't think it's nefarious at all. I
don't read it that >> Sure, most people would. And the
way this article is writing it is portraying it as this shady
dark money thing, right? So I I it's I don't think most people
do. >> hand you think it's not that bad and that's fine.
I I also don't think necessarily this would be that bad. It's
not only if it was for the legal reasons but also if it's like,
"Hey, if I give just like like a hundred bucks and like go buy
me groceries and then you don't." I'm like, "Well, loop me in
what the [__] you did with my money." Yeah, this
is probably reasonable. Can I ask you just why why do you think
most people see it that way?
Why do I think because like of the language of this article portraying
it as this like nefarious secret thing? I disagree with you.
So I'm asking you what what thing what are you checking? What
are you looking at to say this is what it means? What are you
looking at to make your point too? So so you're you're like appealing
to Okay, that's fair. I don't I haven't pulled. I haven't pulled
people.
I'm asking you what you're basing that on other than like it's
you trying to make an argument but you don't have like any evidence
for it so you're just saying it. When you say I don't have evidence,
when I when I click on an article and there's like a big dollar
bill behind this like silhouette of an influencer and it's like,
"Look at this money that's controlling that's astroturfing."
And you agree that it has a sensational subheader that's like,
"All these people have to do is agree with us." >> You
want to say it's astroturfing because of the lack of disclosure,
right? If you were disclosing it wouldn't be astroturfing. Yes,
if it's not fake. Yes, I understand that. >> No, if it's
not if it's not deceptive
it's not that but whether it's fake or >> right? The fake
Well, no, the fake that's why it's called astroturfing, right?
Because it's fake. It's not grassroots. It's not a bunch of people
who really have this deception on grassroots these big people.
What's the deception of grassroots? It's you're being paid for
it. I just like, see any negative I don't think it's bad to pay
people to do it. I'm I'm arguing that you could just It would
not be astroturfing if you weren't lying and then putting a clause
in the contract that says they have to lie.
Or, sorry, not disclose. Not not lie. Not disclose.
Well, first of all, again, I don't know what they're not allowed
to disclose. If it's just the 1630 thing, again, I don't trust
necessarily the language of this >> trust Wired. You don't
trust Wired, their editorial staff, and their legal team. Not
based on what I've just seen. No. I I don't I don't necessarily
think this is portrayed in what I would call a fair way. And
I'm I'm confused cuz like Well, I'm confused cuz like you're
like Let's stick to one of these arguments. Either all of this
stuff is okay, and sure, maybe it is, but then let's stop talking
about whether or not it's true the way they're portraying it.
Because if it is true the way they're portraying it, you still
think it's okay, right?
It's just the disclosure that's bad. Um yeah, the disclosure
stuff's bad.
Okay, but then why even talk about any of the stuff about what
they're allowed to say, who they're talking to, and like funneling
the creators to this this uh tool? Like, why does that matter
if it's just the disclosure that's bad?
Well, I have a different opinion than Taylor Lorenz. Okay, well,
that's my
Okay, but I don't think that means she's
>> that's like all of this stuff is bad and evil. You're
okay with it. I'm okay with it. And we can both look at this
and say, I think she's kind of portrayed this as not bad, but
you're saying no, it's actually understand I don't see my >> Well,
the difference between us is that I don't see my world view as
inherently good and correct. Well, you should. I think I think
everyone should view themselves as correct. No. I think there
are like downsides to the way I see the world, obviously, and
other people see other things that are bad. >> Let's back
up. Wait. Wait. When when Sorry, I'm being annoying. When when
you say this is not portraying this in a negative light, it's
just objectively describing it.
No, I'm saying >> you can say There there is very possibly
some bias there, but hold on, there's a good analogy for this,
and I know you got a hard out here. Are you Are you How quick
are you out here? Uh I mean, look, I'm going to miss my first
game of Magic the Gathering and all my all my friends are going
to be really mad at me, all right? But I can't Let's Let's wrap
it >> give you an analogy, okay? Really really really quickly.
When Trump was first getting, I think, sued in his first
he was given a Mexican judge. And he said, "That Mexican judge
cannot be the judge for my my hearing cuz he's >> Times
or whatever. He's too He's too biased. No, the first thing he
said I can't have a Mexican judge. That was all he said. Oh,
wait, sorry. That was That was the That was the secondary defense.
The first one was that he's just Mexican, yeah, true. Yes. So,
why is it And by the way, do we even Do we Would we even disagree
with that? That probably that guy's a little biased against Trump
cuz he's Mexican.
That's probably true, right? There might be a little, but the
whole point is like you're supposed to be above that.
>> you can't use this as a Supposed to be above that. And
what else? And they go through like uh ethics courses. They have
an entire pipeline and a framework for making their decisions
that guides them and removes and minimizes that bias as much
as possible. Which is what Condé Nast, a hundred-year-old, a
century-old publisher, specializes in. And that's why they went
through Wired. That's why Taylor went through Wired and published
this article.
But is that enough to say and now I can never question the journalistic
integrity of the article? >> But But when you can't point
to things and when you consistently hyperbolize what's happening
in the article and when you consistently misread or misframe
like arguments happening in the article, I'm going to say that
probably you just very much dislike their bias and you want it
more biased in your favor. And that's okay, you can make that
argument, but it's not I don't think we should make that argument
by imputing Taylor Taylor Lorenz's professional credentials.
I don't think we should make that argument by saying that it's
like inherently evil that they're describing Democrats as always
evil. I just I think you should read what's there and I think
you should put forth an argument and I think you should do it
in a positive way that is not necessarily just attacking Taylor
Lorenz because if you do it that way, then I think you could
have a chance at a follow-up article that explains some of the
some of the downsides or some of the bad things that are happening
here or some of the things they could have missed, but when you
always attack, when everybody's just attacking, when Breitbart
and Tucker Carlson comes out right away and goes, "Uh Taylor
Lorenz, you mean the woman who's like getting praised by Candace
Owens and Tucker Carlson?" Yeah, when he does that, you forfeit
all ability to get you forfeit all ability to get charity back
from her. Look, Taylor's recent article that she didn't have
super much time to promote, where she's talking about the dark
money behind these like AI companies, was much better in my opinion.
One, because it just describes the exact pipeline of like, "Hey,
this is why it's dark money. This is how these things aren't
disclosed, and this is why this is influencing people and they
aren't even they don't have all the information they can to like
assess whether or not this is a good thing." This didn't include
any of the stuff that has this language about what I think is
control, and weirdly I think you do too. Now, I'm a little but
the point is this article is not like a indictment like, "Oh,
I hate There's nothing about controlling what they say. It's
about controlling specific engagements that they pay for.
Seems totally fine to me. Wait, wait, wait, okay. See, but see
how we keep doing this jumpy thing, right? Like, you are okay
with these things. I'm okay with a lot of these things, too.
But then you keep saying I'm reading into it and projecting this
negativity on it.
But then is it objectively describing something that people might
view negatively or is it trying to portray it as negative? It's
objectively describing something that people might see portray
like receive as negative.
If you were to read through this article, this just to you reads
like like a like an AP piece that's just like, "And by the way,
this is reality." Not "And they did this, and they did that,
and they're not allowed to do this." Like, I don't understand
how you can look at just >> subheader and that's like somehow
like an outlier. I think any major journalistic outlet would
have run this piece. I don't think it's just Wired.
Well, I don't know if it's whether or not someone would publish
it. I mean, I don't think Reuters or AP would publish this, but
this is like not their language. This is more like >> like
that's because they do factual news
Well, is this not just factual news?
It's like a profile. It's like a It's like a whole investigative
reporting thing. It's not factual news. >> I I seriously
doubt not just that it's Yeah, you're not saying it's op-ed.
Um
I don't know. I just
It does not seem to me that this is at all like some objective
assessment of it when you can look at the way that this is framed
and I'm I'm like we're going through the language and it's like,
okay, this seems to imply and then like you look at the quote
from a creator. It's like, well, that's just the quote from the
creator. It's like, well, why is it in there? Right? The creator
is saying, well, this is much more negative, right? Like I have
to be fully compliant with them. I don't want to give my stuff
to them. Like this isn't an accident. This is framed in between
describing how these contracts work, what course is doing in
a way that is negative, right? It's not >> I totally disagree
that it's particularly negative and I maybe it's just cuz I read
a lot of news and and like opinion pieces not opinion pieces,
but investigative stuff and opinion pieces actually. And I've
seen Actually it is that I've read opinion pieces. I read like
Richard Hanania all the time. I read a whole bunch of lib writers
as well. I see how actual like actual opinion articles are when
they're trying to frame things a certain way and this is not
within It's not within light years of that. So, to me it's like
I don't know, maybe maybe there's a lot of people who just don't
read their news very much.
Maybe. I I mean, I don't I don't read Wired a lot. >> It's
By the way, I don't think you have to read your news, but I think
if you if you read a lot and a lot from different sources, this
is not like somebody pushing a narrative doing like an extreme
framing. It is like a very It feels like a journalistic piece.
Like if if Taylor Lorenz didn't have her name on that article,
I think
I think it would feel the exact same to me. I don't think her
bias actually really informs anything about the article. I think
regardless of her name being on it, regardless of her being the
author, the article would read the same way to me. I wouldn't
read more bias in or less. I would just It would read the same.
It feels like it's been pretty scrubbed, and I feel like any
indicate That's By the way, also, I feel like it really hurts
her reporting here, or at least gives people a way to attack
her when she makes the comments she does after the fact. Which
is something that I would have like to discuss if we had a little
bit more time.
I mean, yeah, but
that's not irrelevant, right? Like It's not irrelevant. No, I
I think that is a legitimate criticism that her tweets and her
commentary after the fact does color the reporting a little bit,
and I wish she hadn't done it.
But it's not irrelevant. >> think the piece stands stands
stands on its own, but I think she's basically given people a
way to attack and discredit her reporting, which she didn't have
to do.
Taylor was just another one of these influencers who like ran
away with this article with the things that you and I agree are
like, these are more negative readings than what the article
is
Would you say that's even close to like the fault of the article,
or is this like people are just completely just projecting their
own biases onto it? It depends on how far they go away from the
outside from the actual thing said by the article. PV I I don't
think there's any indication that Progressive Victory was funded
by Israel. A bunch of people said that. A bunch of people ran
with that. What did PV do to give off that impression?
I I I don't I don't know. I I I heard this once. Are they Does
it matter? No, I'm saying they they weren't, and people just
made that up, but they ran with it. Okay. Right, but if there
was an article that they were basing it off of where it's it
said something like
I don't know. Hey, if you deviated from the party line, and then
also implied the party line was a Israel thing, then would it
be completely unfair for them to run away that way? The party
line Where is she actually describing the party line in a way
that's inaccurate? That's You have to give me where is the inaccuracy
there? >> Well, she doesn't really describe the party line,
which is kind of the problem with it, right? It's just like it's
the party line and because you're being vague with >> Sorry,
in the tweet I'm actually talking about in the tweet I'm actually
talking about in the tweet now. Like Oh, the the Is it not Is
it not within the party line to essentially minimize like what
was going on in Palestine? Was that not well within the party
line? Oh, sure. So, what is the what So so I'm not By by by knowing
the person who wrote it and by the what the article says, would
it be unfair for these I don't think these people were unfair
coming away from this thinking, "Oh, here's this Democrat apparatus
meant to silence people on Gaza, right?" Like the implication
here it leads you to that. That's like why I had the issue with
it cuz maybe that's true and you can make an article about it
and Again, I really don't think it's implied and I we walked
through it and you kept saying kicked out and like I Not invited
>> you're going to read that in no matter what, but it's
just not there. >> out of the like the White House engagements,
right? Or or I know Hassan was kicked out of the DNC, but essentially,
they're not being Hassan was invited to the White House. He didn't
go from what I understand.
Did they not like not let him speak or something like that or
am I crazy? Oh, he eventually got asked to leave the DNC cuz
he was in somebody's spot >> Right. Something about that's
why why the language kicked out keeps popping in my head. Sorry.
>> Or he got he got got asked to leave his booth and he
got asked to leave his booth and he got asked to >> I'll
just be very clear for everybody cuz I know some people won't
like that. He got asked to leave his booth where he had wired
internet and he didn't want to go stream in the area where all
the plebs were where the internet was like dropping out constantly.
So, he went back to his hotel.
I don't know I don't know if he was straight-up out of the DNC
entirely. I believe he was not. But I'll uh I I do think the
correction's important cuz I know I know
Uh nothing. It's I I think people will get mad about it if I
don't correct, so. Okay. Well, listen. >> No, sorry. I
I think Erudite will get mad about it. Erudite was the one who
made it very clear, "Oh, Hassan was not kicked out. Hassan was
not kicked out." All of this I So, I don't want to fight with
anybody. I'm not trying to fight with anybody, okay?
I'm going to tell her you said that and then I'm going to mix
up words to make it look like you said the opposite. So, whatever
makes her the most mad will be the thing that you have to confront.
Um, I got to skedaddle. Uh, I do appreciate you talking with
me and like I I completely disagree with your reading of this,
but regardless like I this was not a screaming annoying match.
So, that was nice and you seem like a nice guy. Although all
the things I hear about all the snarking and back and forth Keep
me out of it, man. I don't want to I don't want to get docked.
Sounds awful. Anyway, my final thoughts are having you on Discord
right now. Like just a tiny bit more of a chat on this when you
have a little bit more time cuz I do think there's like one or
two other things I didn't get to. But yeah, I do know that we're
running out of time. Uh, thank you very much for the conversation.
Yeah, I think I'm going to get a lot of DMs in
Oh god. It's It's just fun to have um, it's fun to have like
actual contentious conversations and most people uh, for whatever
reason are like scared to call into my stream and argue. So,
Hey man, I look at the chat. I I get it and I'm not blaming you
necessarily. I don't know like if most of these people are trying
to attack you, which I'm assuming is probably what That's got
to be DGG, but you know, I get it the other way around on the
other side. So, Where's the other way around? It's just when
I'm getting all the people like, you know, going after me for
talking with Destiny and like all I'm saying is just keep keep
me out of your your I don't know. Volume wise, volume wise how
you feeling? Volume wise you want to rate? I would Oh my god,
what does that mean? Like who who what would I get more from?
No, don't even answer it. Don't even answer. I don't want to
put you on the spot. Look man, how about this? Let's get you
to 4 million subscribers and let's see what happens.
Let's let's let's Let's put me in the middle of two giant creators
who hate each other. I love that. That's cool. All right, thank
you very much for calling. Um, yeah, thanks for the call. Yeah,
have a good one. Yeah, you too.